[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us the lovely colleen again hey
colleen
we're about to talk about something
where she has a lot of experience aren't
we
dancing there we go
filmmaking no i think ryan has more
experience than this
during the break it was funny because
nick was like man i bet dancers get all
the posts that they crush in the world
and i was like yeah you know what
dancers i think they have this like
i don't know they have this kind of like
trope of being like romantic dudes and
they probably like a lot of girls you
know like them and stuff they start
backing it up on people oh that's dude
that's the good did you see the hip
rotation there that's really do a little
bit of
that is really good
with the fanny pack dude
just look at my number
oh
my
wow the the wow the fanny pack flew as a
dancer bro i know i know what it's like
you know what i mean
and colleen's in a she's like neck deep
maybe nose deep in the dance community
right
careful
careful careful
so as a lady in the dance community
how has your experience been
with these sex gods yeah surrounding you
anthony do you think you're a sex god no
i think he is
he is the best that's such a sex god
thing to say absolutely no he said like
this no he said like that's like a
who the [ __ ] says yes
sex minions yeah
people that don't have sex right here
you have like god ordained sex
yeah like yeah yeah i think that's the
best way to say he's not a sex guy he's
just got ordained yeah yeah god blesses
me to have sex yeah because joe was
saying like dude dancer dancers probably
get all the push and i was like dude
honestly like a lot of them are they
they just creep girls out i think people
are initially attracted to the talent
but this is what i was saying off camera
too as soon as they open their mouths
it's a little bit of a different story
what do you mean i don't know if we can
blanket statement dancers on this one
but let's keep talking and see what's
like the stereotypical dancer creep
trope or all the suitors that you have
well think about all the the people who
are being
okay that's different
okay she was talking about all the
cancellations going around
hold on a row is there a me too dance
movement some of the highest like
position dancers were just getting
knocked off their pedestals like one
after the other slush they're just some
creep [ __ ] but you know but then
rightfully so though i think that's a
thing that has to do with a lot of like
art or performance based talents
those are all the coaches always have a
sex with their student huh well i mean
if you especially if you think of
dancers before dancers were dancers they
weren't always the most popular guy in
school so do you think guys they could
have also just been [ __ ] weirdos too
like do you think they get into dance
going like
i'm gonna get something i'm gonna get
some [ __ ] i'm gonna get something dude
honestly there are people that will
message me like like [ __ ] these young
dancers message me for and that is their
motivation i'm like what the [ __ ] what
makes them think all right this is this
is what i don't know that's fair though
because like i admittedly so definitely
started dancing because i thought i was
like oh man maybe girls like this but i
didn't know i would like it more than
girls like me doing it
it turned into a passion you're like
well this is a win-win but what okay
what that's that's what this is what is
going to say
i mean if i've ever heard one
how is this gonna get your [ __ ] uh wait
until you hear that move to the perfect
sound and then you're like oh my god
what would be the perfect sound
wave i only wanna
[Laughter]
what is the dancer creep trope though
yeah what's the i want to know i think
when you're in tell us some stories when
you're in your industry
um you're only you only see your
industry right so like in the comedian
world it's like
some dudes like after the show they'll
start talking and you can immediately go
okay this guy's trying to use the set he
just killed to kind of spit game or
whatever like what is
the dance creep
so people out there i guess can
recognize it
is there like uh find the dance creeps
in your locally right
[Laughter]
what should we be aware of
i mean uh the the big me too moving
cancellation stuff i think a lot of that
comes from like the culture of what they
call the grooming
so you know when you're uh when you're
taking some sort of young prodigy that
is already in your ecosystem because
maybe you teach at a school you know or
a studio that has like uh some sort of
tuition program where kids are
constantly there or there's some youth
team and you happen to be that like you
know uh parental guidance kind of head
figure you know coach whatever you're
taking them to competitions or late
night rehearsals or saying like you know
this is a big competition you can sleep
at my house or whatever or you know
there's a there's a giant retreat or
well conventions that have that issue
is where
people who are traveling with
conventions and they have hotel rooms
you're staying in the same hotel that
all these other kids going to that
convention dude
and that's a huge problem
so with dance conventions those are like
these traveling like uh sometimes week
long seminars where there's like classes
every day and they usually take place in
like a big hotel where like you'll go
teach in the ballroom but then your
rooms are upstairs there have been times
where we were teaching on those shits
and the kids would just go around trying
to find the instructors and like we'll
just knock on your door at like midnight
to do what just to say just to see you
just say hi
it's an innocent thing but it's like yo
you all played
oh there's not the ice machines well
that's what that's what it'd be like so
they're just playing like like oh they
might be in one of these rooms and
they're just like let's go find them but
then then
creep my open go come on in what's
because like if these kids are like fans
of you they just want to interact
they're not it's like an innocent kid
they're trying to like sometimes they're
even just pranking you but you know if
you're that's true if if i was really
looking up to somebody and then like i
you know at midnight i'll be like oh
maybe they want to play like hide and
seek or something
you know like i no yeah it's that
innocent yeah like they'd be like i
would i would want to play with them
dude yeah like this 15 year old girl was
like knocking on our door and i opened i
was like what the [ __ ] and she's like hi
like not just super innocent yeah
she slammed in her face like dude no way
man i tried to jailbait myself it didn't
work you know what you got served his
own i'm gonna watch that instead but
it's always playing in a hotel room you
know uh it's it's also like dance is
such like a um a uh you know passion and
physical kind of art as well right so
you might be in the room and it might be
like you know teaching someone dance
like no you got you want to move like
this or fix this or your body
and it can get into that place show them
how it is show them how it heats up
where it gets comfortable yeah you know
what i mean so
there's definitely people especially
when you're putting into a position of
power or totally take advantage of that
where are the parents at you know what i
mean like they sometimes are they're so
they're attacking the bar getting drunk
yeah or they want their kid to interact
with choreographers to like gain a leg
up in the career or just trusting a
manipulative person who like on the
outside is very doing everything by the
book super responsible super nice right
sometimes the actual creeps are the ones
that are like super easy to hang out
with all the time i never trust they
don't they don't necessarily give you
[ __ ] up vibes it's more just like oh
that person's really nice that's what
the definition of creep is to me it's
not someone who's like going
literally it's like
creep is literal it's like they're
creeping closer and closer to ulterior
ultra motive but they're using dances
like as the vehicle they're like oh yeah
dance me and you blah blah but that has
to build a rapport right and they know
that you like maybe you didn't show like
a physical interest off the bat so then
they're like oh now what i do oh okay
let me just getting close as a friend
through dance and then when the time is
right
[Music]
what a time we're having
[Laughter]
since it started since time started not
having a good time
so you think about like larry nassar and
uh you know uh if you're a young female
gymnast in the olympic team and it's
like oh like all these gold medalists
came through yeah then you get put to
that situation like i guess this is what
it is and those same kind of things or
tropes can kind of also happen in the
ecosystem right you're like i'm gonna
spend some extra time with this
choreographer because they work on like
serious industry [ __ ] or have these
opportunities obviously they're doing
like dope stuff and then maybe you find
yourself in an uncomfortable position
but you're like uh
maybe this is what you got to do because
i remember in a different type of
situation completely i remember
traveling to russia my first time to
teach and then the promoter and this is
like back in the day so you don't get
like a lot of uh experiences or stories
but the promoters is alright cool you're
just teaching this class all right now
you're going to jump on this train and
go to st petersburg um the train is
going to be 12 hours you're going to be
in this bunk uh it's you know i'm
talking about russia it's like there's
like four beds inside of a compartment
and then you're just in there with three
other random russian people that are
also traveling 12 hours
and i remember thinking to myself like
really like this is what i'm supposed to
do and then the organizer who's totally
sweet and cool was just like oh yeah
this teacher did it this teacher this
this teacher did it suddenly i'm kind of
like i guess that's what i have to do
and i put myself in a position that like
nine out of 10 times i wouldn't have
done that is that like a hostel on a
train is it kind of yeah but i'm just
i'm just showing the example of being
like oh okay if i like you're just out
of your element you just don't know how
you can slowly be walked into a
situation yeah i see yeah yeah so then
sometimes when you see somebody dancing
as a coach you don't know if that sweat
is from physical or from perversion
that's true yes
that's true metaphorically
[Applause]
he's rubbing his mustache all the time
i can bring up that clip so you know
what i'm referencing it it's not me it's
not original material editor editor no
editor note so like so like the the
misconception of like rico suave dance
dudes is actually like what what would
you say that might be true in latin
dance sure because i know that's like
that's pretty prevalent like you hear a
lot of [ __ ] like that going down but for
the dance that we're involved romantic
dance man i don't know it doesn't seem
to differ very much from just anything
else yeah you know like just someone
with just a bad motive you know now
they're just really i mean like i mean
like so let's say
okay so i'm i'm pretty sure that the
guys of dance might have more chances
with romance and dating than maybe the
guys of engineering you know anything
that you can display some form of like
prowess without speaking you're right
it's you had a benefit because you could
be the dumbest idiot and someone could
just be in an audience watching you and
then going like oh i like him but like
based on what you know like it probably
depends on the type of dance because if
it's like tap versus break dancing or
why why you [ __ ] on tap bro like
that's way more attractive then well has
that ever happened to you where you were
working with a dancer and they started
making it more about like more than work
and you were just they started tapping
in front of you
no honestly i actually have never ran
into that scenario i don't know do you
think you have a good spider sense of
like man you trying to [ __ ] do
something else
or you just like
you know i mean like like when you run
into these situations like i take it for
face value until somebody shows me that
there is a clear line being drawn
like i'll let you be what about any like
boom mic operators
it starts bumping your
what are you doing yo god damn it
immediately immediately x down
which style is
the sexiest yeah and then which style is
usually you find the lamest guys
i think whatever style that you're doing
that comes across most authentic no is
there something yes because
yeah he doesn't like this that's not the
right answer
because i think
if you're doing something that's
authentic and it comes across that way
it doesn't look like you're trying too
hard yeah because like although uh the
the the river dancers out there just
like my [ __ ] is the [ __ ] real [ __ ]
those things that they do in [ __ ] las
vegas is so fake effortless what about
like a so let's say a crumper is like
i'm gonna do a poem for you in my face
would you take that as oh man that guy's
sweet yeah i would think that he has
epilepsy
so you're not a fan of dance then it
sounds like clearly
all right in your experience of dating
right
um
if if uh which industry or like kind of
hobby or or
subculture has the most
like
romantic
kind of suave dudes
that sweep you off you guys do this
across the gym when we like lock eyes
and he has a book
you just can't get away from this guy
the lead extra in my life
anybody any any uh any memories of
anything like
featured extra tantalizing males are
always there
i guess with the hardest
unicyclists there's not like a checklist
where you're like this is gonna be the
most i know but it's funnier yeah
yeah well
put it in a box put it in a freaking box
it's in a [ __ ] box yeah you got a box
yes it says shanghainese oh that's so
attractive
is it choice is it like uh if uh if this
guy knows how to move is there any
correlation like if this person knows
how to move maybe they know how to move
bust it down that's like the common
thought right process but i also think a
guy who doesn't know how to move that's
a turn off
oh he just doesn't feel out of here
he's just like he woke up this way i've
not learned yet
stupid
stupid i've not learned yet
in the 35 years of my life colleen will
you teach me
i also don't know how to move nurse i'm
back to hell he's a new robot fresh out
of the factory he's a new mover you're
canceled that's handicap
when uh when did you start dancing
colleen
when did i start dancing i started
dancing
late 15 15. that's late and like
competition yeah that's like sounds late
like so what's the average age of three
three three
for real it depends on the style all
three-year-olds dance by the way well i
was a studio
so like most kids are in ballet and jazz
and all that like three starting studio
at 15 is late yeah for sure yeah for
studio that's late and when you say
studio what does that mean i'm not
you're receiving proper training oh yeah
so most kids that are into dance they
start as a toddler
like a [ __ ] russian contour a lot of
the really good people that you'll see
you'll they'll be like like if you go to
something really really good dancers
instagram they'll be on thursdays
there'll be a video of them as a [ __ ]
kid like on stage you're like damn oh
like like okay when they're wearing the
sequins
also the dichotomy is oftentimes uh it's
not 100 but it's like oftentimes like
studio train versus maybe like street
styles or something like that so like
for example ryan i'm assuming again uh
he was probably just learning uh street
style dancing but never really went into
the studio to learn like formal
classical training what what what studio
what are some classical styles for
studio jazz tap ballet contemporary
modern and you have to take all of them
so it's yeah yeah you have to take
there's like a tui uh like an actual um
curriculum intuition like algebra
algebra two whatever it's like
whereas like i started in 18 at 18
at uci so like as
as like late as it gets and as cliche as
it was i remember like me and mike and
victor we would like literally take
carbo boxes and put them in the [ __ ]
little garage and try to learn [ __ ] i'll
be hurting myself all the time but that
was like we're like oh this is the
street style you know what i'm saying
we're streets out too
are you in your garage
when did you have that moment when you
found the clock
wait yours your your classical or your
studio no no no oh cause i thought you
found a street man and then he taught
you
[Laughter]
like a bum that teaches you a buddhist
bomb
he saw anthony's like this guy you got
real there's a guy at third street
promenade he's like you can you please
teach me like get out of here i'm trying
to make money
i remember for the first few years i
never made it into a dance studio
yeah i mean like literally never went to
a dance to the first few years first
time the first couple times that we
would like practice at a gym not even a
designated dance space but just like a
gym that had an open area i remember
being like this is luxury when was the
first proper class you took as a day at
millennium shauna varisto is at focus
dance center what age
20 or 21. holy [ __ ] so at that time you
only had what three years of training
like training my first year at 18 i i
was too scared to join a choreo team so
i went to the uci b-boy club for like a
year and just learned like uh breaking
and popping and then the next year i'll
audition for a team and then the next
year i went to my first class did you
pick up korea fast i yeah i pick up fast
but uh technique still took me just as
long as anybody else you know what i
mean i mean that's to be expected yeah
but i had a fast pick i have a fast
pickup because the probably taekwondo
like the forms i i always like to think
that things like forms in taekwondo and
like playing video games like hand-eye
coordination and timing were things that
helped me be able to piece those things
together um but when did you take all of
those things you learned and begin to
channel it into mackin on the ladies
yeah that's the real question
when i first started breaking i think
it's a lot of people right like the very
first thing people like some people be
like yo you gotta learn like a little
bit of foundation i'm like yo can we
learn some windmills i think you see
women
windmills
so today we have a woman
teaching me how to
are there any um
dance women creeps yeah
sure
like
late at night you know what i mean and
you're like i can't that's like a
husband and wife duo yeah
oh yeah
in florida yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah
from me what happened yeah this is a
group out in florida i'm not going to
say the name again but it's a whole girl
group and they're all full of creeps no
there's there's like for example one
girl group
one dance team uh that was very very
like won a lot of competitions in our
american community it's like highly
prolific yeah specifically led mainly by
like one dude and his wife
uh they were uh outed in this whole slew
of community me too type stuff what do
they do orgies
no more like uh aggressive and forced
you know um
stuff with youngins so they're they're
the epstein and glenn maxwell of the
dance low key it sounded like that again
i don't want to say anything um yeah
because this stuff didn't actually go to
trial it just was like it's a ledge
people a bunch of people just did a ton
of ig lives talking about but you got
like literally like like ladies from you
know these dance teams and stuff going
on ig lives during this time this
coronavirus pandemic time you know
people are like all on the phones always
and they're they're giving these
accounts and they're very detailed
there's like tears there's people
jumping on to there's corroborators of
all their stories yeah and it gets
really intense you know what i mean so
um that kind of stuff for sure happens
but i think to answer the the concept of
the question i mean if if men can do it
for sure women can too but i do will say
statistically from everything we see in
here seems a lot more uh men are the
predators in these situations yeah even
the predators of men be man i mean that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] happened with breaking a
lot like uh
with uh because you know breaking so
mail driven and then when girls want to
learn there's always a guy that's like
oh i'll teach you there's always a
perverted coach yeah there's always that
i teach you moment and it's kind of
weird too because you really wear my
home studio okay
i never why is it
on the bench
spins faster baby
you want to be the best
yeah it's like uh even even one of like
my personal hero's uh crazy legs
he had some [ __ ] happen to him where
like he had a crazy dick
you know it you don't picture that dick
doing a sixth it just like goes crazy
all the time
no he got some [ __ ] he didn't i don't
think he actually like i don't know i
only don't even know it someone was
complaining that uh
that he was like hitting on him and [ __ ]
when he shouldn't have been
i think he was just like you know making
girls uncomfortable while he was in a
position of like you know
because that's a hard thing right like
you get put into put on that pedestal
yeah the lines are so much more
different from any other social
interaction you know guys gotta shoot
their shot outside of their workplace
yeah don't [ __ ] where you eat i mean
like well if you're
maybe you can shoot your shot to a
superior no you can't do that but you
have more of an advantage because when i
train people i i load up the barbell
like crazy right and i have them walk it
out so they're literally life or death
and then i ask them on the date and then
if they say no then i just tap the top
of the bottle they get crushed
personal trainer secrets
my what a time we're having
we're gonna find that [ __ ] man i'm gonna
look like a [ __ ] crazy guy
[Music]
you